today on the Matt wall show The Daily
Show hosted by Chelsea Handler defends
and promotes childlessness we're told
that not having children is great
because it means that you can sit in hot
tubs and go on vacations among other
things I'll pick through all the
problems with that argument today also
our Sports show here at the daily wire
training companies breaking some news
today about Leah Thomas the male swimmer
who claims to be a woman the details are
repulsive but important plus the White
House now says that the UFOs invading
our airspace are probably just used car
balloons right in our daily cancellation
a New York Times columnist dedicates an
entire essay to responding to one of my
tweets we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
all right
you know when the going gets tough you
could always count on big Tech said no
one ever we all know big business
especially big Wireless is always
looking to lock you down into multi-year
contracts with huge penalties Pure Talk
is the antidote to woke wireless
companies they are the only Wireless
company that offers a 100 money back
guarantee they're so sure you're going
to love their service that if you don't
they'll give you your money back but uh
I have a feeling you are going to love
the service stop paying for Verizon 18t
or T-Mobile cut your bill in half with
pure talk their us-based customer
service team makes the switch really
easy switch over to Pure Talk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone number and your phone as well your
first month is guaranteed risk free so
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Walsh to save 50 off your first month
that's puretalk.com promo code Walsh
short talk is simply smarter Wireless
well if you want to understand modern
American society the first thing you
need to realize is that lots of people
are very unhappy and those unhappy
people tend to think that their
unhappiness can be cured by majority
vote essentially if they can convince
other people to live the way that they
live and do the things that they do and
become as as unhappy as they are then
magically it will have the effect of
making them happy and in a similar way
they believe that if they can convince
everyone else that they are not unhappy
even though they are indeed deeply and
tragically unhappy then they will become
happy and if none of those strategies
work of course which they don't then
there's always antidepressants which
also don't work
what I've just described could of course
be summarized by the cliche misery loves
company and that as it happens would
also be a great title for Chelsea
Handler's autobiography if she ever
writes one not that the title of a book
that nobody will read really matters
Chelsea Handler of course uh is a
comedian at least I've gathered based on
context clues that she's a comedian or
trying to be one anyway never actually
heard her tell anything that can be
immediately recognized as a joke that is
unless we step back and view her career
through a wider lens and see that her
entire career is the joke maybe this is
some sort of like performance art that
she's doing
and if that's what she's going for then
she is pulling it off uh and masterfully
so I have to say now recently Handler
took uh the job of guest host on The
Daily Show after Trevor Noah's departure
and we can't be sure what the producers
had in mind when they hired a shrill
unfunny spinster with all the wit and
charm of a bitter middle-aged woman
standing in line at Target while loudly
complaining that they don't have enough
registers open I can only assume that
there are maybe some Trevor Noah
loyalists still on the staff who wanted
to find someone who could manage to make
him seem funny in retrospect maybe
that's what's going on whatever the
thought process it didn't take Handler
very long to steer the show in the only
Direction she knows how to go which is
desperately justifying her own life
choices especially her choice to not
have children
actually I need to amend that slightly
because it's not that Handler has chosen
not to have children it's that she's
chosen not to allow any of her children
to live she is childless today thanks to
the three abortions that she often brags
about she doesn't have any living
children we should say she is however
the mother of three dead children babies
who are sacrificed on the altar of her
quote-unquote Freedom a freedom that was
purchased with the blood of her own
children
just to clarify that's what we're
talking about
recently as many people have seen in
viral clips of the show Handler
dedicated an episode to defending and
promoting her child-free lifestyle
now normally nothing involving Chelsea
Handler or The Daily Show for that
matter is worth talking about
but in this case she inadvertently
raises I think a few points a few
important points that are worth
discussing so I think it's worth
spending a little bit of time on this so
here's Chelsea
something that I have made abundantly
clear is that I do not want children I
say it on stage I say it in interviews
it's the first thing I say to myself in
the mirror when I wake up each morning
right before I tell myself God you're a
dynamic woman
[Applause]
kids don't respect me and quite frankly
the feeling is mutual and the fact is
there are millions of women just like me
but for some reason every single one of
us at some point in our lives is shamed
by Society for not wanting a baby and
that's what I want to talk about in
tonight's installment of long story
short
well actually Chelsea Society wouldn't
know or especially care that you don't
have kids nobody's running up to you on
the street screaming hey where are your
babies you better have babies
rather you know you often talk about
your decision to be childless and you
talk about it in the most obnoxious ways
you possibly can which gives everyone
else in society the right to give their
own opinion about your choices and the
reasoning behind those choices
this is the way it works and something
that everyone needs to understand
because a lot of people struggle with
this you see when you present your
lifestyle choice to the public
when you go on TV and talk about it in
front of millions of people or at least
hundreds of people in the case of The
Daily Show you have submitted that
lifestyle choice for public discussion
you cannot go to the public and say hey
guess what here's a fact about me and
the way that I live my life you can't do
that and then get offended when people
say well here's my opinion about that
you gave that information to us people
naturally form opinions about the
information you tell them now nobody has
the right to go banging on your front
door and demanding to know how many kids
you have but everyone has the right to
form opinions about the unsolicited
information you give them don't want
their opinion well then don't tell them
about it
now let's listen to her continue to tell
us about it
in America and honestly everywhere
motherhood is treated as a woman's
Central purpose in life as if our
destiny is to let a tiny stranger rip a
hole through our Pikachu from the inside
out and then as soon as we turn 18 we're
just supposed to sit back and wait for
Nick Cannon to impregnate us
yeah you see it's funny because she made
a reference to pop culture we all know
that a statement is automatically
hilarious when it refers to Something in
pop culture that we all recognize you
don't need to have an actual punch line
no joke is needed simply say hey you
guys remember this thing from pop
culture and then wait for the uproarious
laughter to commence especially if
you're in front of the studio audience
where they're instructed to laugh and it
really works
next we hear testimonials from other
childless women who have been viciously
discriminated against by Society they
claim and the Ode to childlessness goes
on for for a while longer and it leads
eventually to this
those are right about 1
St a grand fee the other day realizing
how miserable I am I'm miserable on the
beach
and then here I am miserable on the top
of a mountain
and then here I am miserable scuba
diving
and then I'm miserable again smoking a
joint in a hot tub
hey it's truly a new circle of hell for
me
the simple truth is that I'm not having
a kid because I'm happier without them
and that's really not of anyone's
concern but my own
and no I don't hate kids I just don't
want them that's what's so great about
nieces and nephews I love being an aunt
I'm crushing that role guess who gave
each one of them their first edible this
girl
[Applause]
I see Chelsea your 47
years old so giving drugs to kids
doesn't make you a cool ant it makes you
a creep and worse
also if your decision to not have any
living children is not anyone's concern
but your own then why did you dedicate a
10-minute segment on national TV to it
once again that's the question
well you did it as we established at the
beginning partly because you're trying
to convince yourself of your own
happiness this partly explains virtually
everything that any leftist says about
almost any subject
it's it's it's almost always at least in
part a game of them convincing
themselves that they're happy with the
way they've chosen to live their lives
and also you did it because you wish to
promote your empty miserable lifestyle
in the hopes that more people will join
you in it
and it's for that latter reason that I
feel compelled to make two points in
response
first
I must again point out
that you're 47 years old nothing wrong
with being 47
. the point is that you could have had
kids and yet still be at this point
climbing all the mountains and hanging
out on all the beaches that you want
because children don't stay toddlers
forever they grow up
okay if you had a child at the age when
the average woman in America has
children these days even though I mean
that average age is is going up and and
it's getting older and older but even
now after after that process has
happened uh your child would be about 21
years old right now if you follow the
sort of the average trajectory
and if your child followed the average
trajectory by the time you're in your
early 50s your child would be married
with a child of Their Own the point is
that at your age you could have all of
your precious freedoms all of your
vacations all the time in the hot tub
that you want all the time to to sleep
in that you want especially if you don't
have a job and also a family
see you're too old now to use this
argument that you want to make
to use the argument of like yeah see you
see how easy my life is I don't have to
get up in the morning with a screaming
baby that might work when you're still
not a compelling argument but like at
least it's relevant when you're 28
because if you were 28 and you had a kid
there's a very good chance a kid would
be a baby you can't do that when you're
47. there are very few 47 year olds even
ones with uh with with lots of kids that
are waking up in the middle night with a
baby
you know it's like going up to somebody
who just finished a marathon and
bragging that you get to sit down and
relax and you don't have to run a
marathon well the person who just
finished it also can sit down and relax
yet they get to do it with the knowledge
that they finished a marathon so you're
both relaxing now but only one of you
ran a marathon
who's in the better spot indeed who can
who can enjoy that relaxation more
see that's a factor that isn't often
taken into consideration but it's an
important life lesson
as a childless person
um you don't get to experience the joys
of having children obviously
but you also don't really get to
experience the benefits of not having
children
you don't actually experience that
or I should say you might experience
them but you don't appreciate them you
can't
you see you've always been able to sleep
in you've never had to wake up in the
middle of the night with a crying baby
you've always been able to sit in the
hot tub whenever you want you've always
been able to take vacations wherever and
whenever you want you've never known
what it's like to not have any of that
which means you can't experience all of
the joy of having it
the only people who can truly enjoy not
running a marathon are those who've run
marathons it only makes sense for
someone who's run marathons to wake up
in the morning and say man I'm glad I'm
not running a marathon today
for all the rest of us that's just that
we've never experienced it before so
every day is not running a marathon so
we never really have that moment of but
thank God I'm not running a marathon
this is the Catch-22 of Life only the
people who've done something can enjoy
not doing that same thing
so older people who've raised young
children and have now moved past that
phase of Life certainly do feel relief
that they no longer have to deal with
some of the challenges that come with
that phase they also look back and and
miss a lot of that okay you talk to any
47 year old who's had kids and they've
moved past it you're going to hear them
say a lot about how I miss those days
man I really miss those days but they're
also parts of those days that they don't
miss they don't they don't miss having
to wake up in the middle of the night or
wake up early in the morning with it
with a kid they don't miss that
they're relieved to be past that
but you don't have that relief because
you never were in that phase you didn't
earn the relief they did so they feel it
in a way that you never will
then again I should also note that even
parents of young children can sit can
still sit in hot tubs and go to go to
the beach and enjoy uh and even climb
mountains if they want
it may take more planning it may involve
complications that you don't have to
deal with uh if you don't have kids but
despite popular misconceptions you don't
have to put your life on hold when you
have kids you don't have to give up
really any of the things you like to do
or any of your passions
I mean provided that they're uh you know
they're they're fruitful and and good
things
instead you learn to be intentional with
your time you learn to make good use of
the time that you have and that's a
skill that you Chelsea would have done
well to acquire but you clearly never
did second
and finally
having children and this is maybe the
most important point
having children will not automatically
make anyone happy that's true okay
nobody is claiming that if you have a
baby you will immediately become
unspeakably happy and you'll remain that
happy forever experiencing an unbroken
chain of pure uncomplicated Joy until
the day you die that is not the case and
nobody has ever said that it's the case
in fact if you're determined to be
miserable as a parent
there will be many opportunities
presented to you to be as miserable as
you want to be
no the point is that parenting opens up
the possibility for Joy unique kinds of
joy that are simply not available and
are indeed in some ways inconceivable to
non-parents
so the happiness that you're talking
about Chelsea vacations and hot tubs and
so on
these are self-centered things you're
happy because of the comfort and
entertainment that's being provided to
you
there's nothing wrong with that in
moderation everyone is familiar with
that kind of happiness
and it's available to everyone parents
and non-parents alike
but the joy of parenting in a family
life
is a joy found in caring for someone
else
and that is a joy that you Chelsea have
never in your life experienced ever
you you can't conceive of it you don't
know what it is you have lived your
whole life
without it and will die without it and
will be worse for it
this is the joy in giving in loving it's
the joy found in the bond that holds
families together it's a simple joy and
it's free
and it's more pure and more beautiful
than any joy that can be provided to you
by a vacation resort
it's a joy that if you open yourself to
it makes you a better person it makes
you less selfish less superficial less
focused on your own needs and wants in
other words
a parent who opens themselves up to the
joy of Parenthood will become well a lot
less like Chelsea Handler
and that is perhaps the best
advertisement for parenting that I can
offer
offer now let's get to our headlines
well I hope you uh had a good
Valentine's Day
um
I uh I I think that ours I think that
ours was pretty good uh I don't know
what my wife would say but you know she
said she wanted to watch a romantic
comedy last night
um very cliche stereotypical Valentine's
Day type of thing is after weight dinner
kids don't bet she said she wanted to
watch a romantic comedy and then she she
even said there was a new one with
Jennifer Lopez I was like I didn't even
know that she was still making movies
apparently she is but I convinced my
wife instead to watch the 1997 Kurt
Russell action flick breakdown which is
a which is a movie where Kurt Russell
gets kidnapped by evil truckers and he
has to go and kill them all and rescue
her from the kidnappers and it's a great
film it's seriously underrated by the
way I think it's one of my favorite
films certainly one of my favorite
actions likes of the 90s and I talked
her into watching that instead and she
was not impressed
um which look I understand it's not a
romantic comedy but but it is a romance
he rescues his wife from Evil murderous
truckers what is more romantic than that
and there's you know there's not a lot
of Comedy there is a scene at the end
spoiler alert where Kurt Russell throws
the main bad guy over a bridge and then
he's like lying at the bottom uh you
know in this Ravine and his body's
broken on on all the Rocks but he's
still alive
and then this semi truck Falls right on
top of and it's pretty funny like it's
to me it's funny so you've got romance
and you've got comedy together maybe not
and maybe not in a holistic way but it's
there
and uh so
I thought it was a good Valentine's Day
viewing but apparently not you live and
learn no Kurt Russell action movies on
Valentine's Day it's fine
but at least I mean last year we went to
Cracker Barrel on Valentine's Day so you
know this was at least a step up from
that
all right so I want to start with um
with this our friends over at uh Crane
and Company this great Sports show here
at the daily wire
um have are breaking some news this
morning and it starts with Riley Gaines
who is uh one of the female Collegiate
swimmers
who competed against Leah Thomas who is
the male swimmer pretending to be a
female and was allowed to compete
against women O'Reilly Gaines is one of
the few women who was directly impacted
by this and has had the courage to speak
out not the only one but one of the few
and they had an interview with Riley
Gaines I think we have a a brief clip of
that interview let's go ahead and play
that
if we let it there will be men
pretending to be women that ruin women's
sports but ranking first was the person
I had never heard of before and of
course this name was Leah Thomas Leah
Thomas did in fact formerly swim on the
men's team for three years I thought
surely the NCAA wouldn't let this person
compete with us the NCAA official looks
at me and says great job y'all tied um
The Trophy goes to Leah and he said well
for photo purposes Leah has to have it
wow Leah Thomas who used to be will
Thomas is now dating someone that used
to be a man that's now a woman and they
consider themselves lesbians very
interesting Dynamic the things they
practice actively are interesting they
cut off parts of their Mill Parts but
left other parts these testicles are in
a jar stop we were being sidelined to
validate the feelings and the identity
of a man
okay so there's uh some of what was
revealed and uh Jake crane is on his
Twitter account has laid out a thread
this morning with a lot of this
information
[Music]
um at J crane underscore if you want to
go see for yourself so I'll read a
little bit from this
and this is what it says
uh says this is a thread we never
expected to write we sat down with NCAA
Women's swimmer Riley Gaines and she
shared some info about Leo Thomas so we
did some digging and now we have a lot
of questions is this what the NCAA
thinks a woman is warning what we found
is jarring
and I don't know if that's an
intentional pun given some of the
information we find out later the
jarring part but there's some literal
jarring that has gone on apparently
Leah Thomas appears to have two
Instagram accounts his public account
Leah K Thomas featuring a small handful
of generic photos promoting messages
like let trans kids play then a private
account which is Leah basically Leah
timmis with an I rather than an o in our
research we found the observance
um uh someone Nicole walro's name who
identified multiple IG posts about Auto
gynophilia that Leah Thomas under the
account Leah timmis allegedly engaged
with AGP aragonophilia is a males
propensity to be sexually aroused by the
thought of himself as a female
a similar image like by Leah timmis is
still found on Instagram account
um of uh of Gwen weisskopp which is
Leah's alleged romantic partner
Gwen who identifies Leah as his
girlfriend is also a quote unquote
transgender woman according to a
GoFundMe for Gwen's breast augmentation
he's also an unlicensed social worker
living in Philadelphia
um
and then more information about this
person
um
lots of some of the stuff I don't want
to read it's so disgusting
are Gwen and Leah in an exclusive couple
or in a polyamorous sex pod one user
called Cry Baby held
writes nice polycule like by Gwen on a
photo of Leah Gwen and two other trans
people in the post Gwen tags a third
member via stuffed animal in bed with
Leah
so then apparently there's some sort of
poly Amorous thing going on
um and
later on we hear about
Gwen posted a mysterious round-shaped
organ looking item in a clear Ball jar
so does this mean that testicles were
removed and put in a jar I guess were
left to speculate about that there's
some Satanism stuff
um a lot of very disturbing images as
well that they dug up and all of this is
you know it's posted to the internet but
it was on a lot of the stuff is on
private accounts some of it was on
Public Accounts just nobody took the
time to go and find it now
so what's the point here
I think the point's rather obvious
um
it's not surprising to me anyway that
Leah Thomas is a depraved pervert
according to the information that they
found here
that doesn't surprise me
um
but what it reveals and and rather what
it what it confirms with any thinking
person should have already known really
is that this is all this is a fetish
okay this is a this is a a a fetish
Community if we could even call it a
community and that's what it is Auto
gynophilia
okay is as it says there in the thread
ottogynophilia is the men who are
who are uh
thrilled by the thought of themselves as
a woman
okay they they they get off on the idea
of themselves being a woman
which by the way
that is not the same thing as actually
thinking that you are one
that's the important point now even if
Leah Thomas actually believed that he is
a woman that wouldn't at all make him a
woman and so it wouldn't change much or
it shouldn't
but it becomes all the more grotesque
and absurd when you consider the fact
that even these people who claim to
identify as women many of them really
don't they don't even believe what
they're saying about themselves and yet
we're supposed to believe it this is a
fetish
he gets a thrill out of pretending to be
a woman and walking around like a woman
and going into the women's locker room
it's a thrill it's a fetish thing and so
what we're being told is we have to
participate in your fetish
Leah Thomas becomes sexually excited by
the idea of other people seeing him as a
woman and by competing against women in
uh you know in women's sports it's all
part of a fetish and what the women in
these sports are being told is that you
it's not even that you have to affirm
his self-perception
as Twisted as that would be on its own
it's actually that you must participate
in this man's fetish
okay he gets turned on by the by by the
idea of himself as a woman and and even
more so if you uh participate in that
charade and so you have to participate
because he has a right to act out his
depraved fetish
um in public and with your participation
that's what the women are being told
and as I've been saying for so long this
is the case
it's impossible to know for sure of of
all the people these days who claim to
be trans or whatever it's we can't see
inside their minds so we don't know
exactly what's going on we can't say for
sure all we all we can talk about is
what is the physical reality and so we
know that they are not they claim to be
a certain thing and they're not that
thing we know that because we understand
physical reality
but there's a lot of very good evidence
some of it in this thread here
that even if we could see inside their
minds
um they are they are not they're
misrepresenting in public what their own
perception is
and for a lot of these men in particular
they don't even actually see themselves
as women they they know that they aren't
that's the whole point of the fetish is
to pretend to be something that they're
not
Auto gynophilia explains can't say what
the percentage is but it's a large
percentage of these trans quote-unquote
trans men
especially especially the The Men Who uh
quote unquote transition later in life
even if it's when they're 19 or 20 uh
but in particular the cases you know
think about someone like Rachel Levine
transitions as middle-aged man
this is not someone who the whole time
really thought of himself as a woman and
perceived himself that way
this was a a sexual fetish that he
finally decided that he was going to
dedicate his entire life to and and also
require everyone else to participate in
that
that's what so much of this is
now for women
it's often a very different thing
especially adolescent uh girls who get
caught up in this for them it is you
know you know social contagion it's
um it is self-loathing it's fear about
their own bodies and the way that their
bodies are changing uh it's you know
it's it's a lot of that it's like um
it's a a
fear and loathing of of who they are
that's being expressed in this way
foreign
kinds of motivations that lead per a
person to this conclusion of claiming to
be trans
but the really important Point again
is that
um
you know we often talk about these
people and say Well they're confused
in many cases they're not even really
confused
you know they understand what the
reality is but they have other
motivations
and that's the case for Leah Thomas
pretty clearly
Nikki Haley announced her candidacy for
President yesterday and uh here's Whoopi
Goldberg on The View trying to explain
trying to explain why she opposes it
yeah
the Republican plan I hate to ruin it
for you
Republican playing field for the 2024
presidential race just got a little
bigger former South Carolina Governor
Nikki Haley released a campaign ad
making her pitch to the people take a
look
my parents reminded me and my siblings
every day how blessed we were to live in
America some look at our past as
evidence that America's founding
principles are bad
they say the promise of freedom is just
made up some think our ideas are not
just wrong but racist and evil nothing
could be further from the truth Joe
Biden's record is abysmal but that
shouldn't come as a surprise the
Washington establishment has failed us
over and over and over again
it's time for a new generation of
leadership
you should know this about me I don't
put up with bullies and when you kick
back it hurts them more if you're
wearing heels I'm Nikki Haley and I'm
running for president
so Nikki
you know since you have been asleep all
this time and you just woke up
you're just finding out that there are
things about our country that are not
perfect
to pretend that it is and that nothing
happened is ridiculous so you're not
saying anything
and you of all people should know better
because you used to actually have some
sanity and knew right from wrong yes and
then you lost your mind and went in some
new Direction so don't do that
what what how
what what are you basing any of that on
what where why is that your response to
the clip that you just played
see this is just and I don't I don't
support the Kaylee's candidacy as I said
yesterday and I'll talk in a minute
about some more specific reasons why I
don't but but this is just people on the
left Democrats like trying to find a
reason
to oppose Nikki Haley who's a very you
know very kind of benign
um establishment conservative type
figure
and they're trying to find a reason to
oppose or they don't really have a
reason it's just like it's it's uh it's
a reflex all they know about her is that
she's Republican that's all they really
need to know
and this is in spite of all the efforts
that Nikki Haley has made to appeal to
people like that
Nick Haley's made many efforts to appeal
to the Whoopi Goldbergs of the world and
the women of The View
and even after all that effort
this is what she gets in response
which is why
it's a very bad idea to waste your time
trying to appeal you sacrifice your
integrity and your principles for the
sake of appealing to people who will
never accept you ever
unless you abandon entirely even the
facade of being conservative and say I
denounce all of that I renounce all of
that
um now I'm a I'm a left-wing Progressive
I'm sorry for everything I ever said if
you do that
then yeah maybe they'll accept you sort
of but they're not going to let you live
down the fact that you they're they're
never even even then they're not going
to really forgive you
for for having ever dare disagree with
them
but that's the most amount of acceptance
you could ever hope if you don't do that
anything short of that there will be no
acceptance at all so there's no point
a guy named Gavin sample compiled a
tweet thread of uh all the reasons that
he opposes Nikki Haley's candidacy and I
happen to agree with many of these
reasons and I kind of illustrates the
point that I was just making
so I'm going to run through
what some of what he is compiled for
those of us who don't you know maybe uh
have not been keeping very close track
of Nikki Haley I don't remember
everything she's ever said here's just a
few few uh highlights or maybe we should
say low lights
Gavin sample writes Nikki Hill is
running for president here's a list of a
few reasons no one should vote for her
number one Nikki Haley fell for the
Bubba Wallace hate hoax
and then he reposted this tweet from
extremely embarrassing in hindsight and
in fact was embarrassed not hindsight it
was embarrassing in the moment
because any thinking person knew in the
moment that the whole bubble Wallace
story was ridiculous
uh the claim that someone planted a
noose in a in a NASCAR garage was always
absurd but this is what Nikki Haley
wrote at the time
we should all stand with Bubba Wallace
today against the cowards who secretly
put the Noose in his garage stall watch
your back cowards Bubba has a bigger
Army than you do hashtag hate won't win
hashtag we stand with Bubba
um
then he writes uh some other examples
Nikki Haley opposes combat combating big
Tech censorship
um she wrote 2020 also censorship by big
tech companies especially since typical
conservative opinions violates the
spirit of the law and the First
Amendment but more regulations would go
too far in the other direction putting
bureaucrats and lawyers in control of
what gets said online either way free
speech loses
um Nikki Haley has been a squish when it
comes to immigration he brings that up
Nikki Haley removed the Confederate flag
from South Carolina state capitol after
the 2015 Charleston church shooting
and Gavin writes her decision can easily
be seen as the first Monument removal
that sparked the entire movement this
has led to many more statues and
monuments of Confederate generals also
Teddy Roosevelt Thomas Jefferson and
even George Washington being removed
um
that's an important point
that this was not
uh it wasn't like she got caught up
in the hysteria of taking down all the
Confederates flags and monuments and
everything
wasn't even that she actually kicked it
off arguably
she also wrote this uh again in 2020
after George Floyd
we spent the last couple of days
celebrating our son's graduation tonight
I turned on the news and I'm heartbroken
it's important to understand that the
death of George Floyd was personal and
painful for many
in order to heal it needs to be personal
and painful for everyone
that is precisely what the left people
like AOC and ilhan Omar and others
Rasheed Talib and all the rest of the
squad that's precisely what they were
saying to justify looting and rioting
well these people feel pain and so
everyone needs to feel their pain
even though they actually aren't
inflicting that they're they're
inflicting that pain on other people in
their Community not even on the rest of
us
now there are other things that he
brings up but I think these three alone
really tell you everything you need to
know about Nikki Haley and any other
Republican who did the same thing
you know it's just I I can never trust
you I could never I could never trust
you as a leader
when you failed in these moments Bubba
Wallace
the Confederate uh taking down the
Confederate flag and then and then
George Floyd those three things you got
those three things wrong
and uh and that's just it
doesn't mean I'm gonna hate you forever
as a person but it means that I can
never trust you as a leader
because those are the moments when your
leadership is needed the most and if
you're not there when it's needed the
most
then how can I trust you in any other
situation
for all this stuff
you know going along with the bubble
walls thing shows number one a
willingness to go along with the crowd
it also shows that you are easily duped
in a way that is very concerning either
you're easily duped or you're willing to
pretend that you've been duped to go
along with the crowd
um George Floyd again you know going
along with the crowd saying things that
that can only be construed as as
promoting and justifying rioting and
looting and then when it comes to
Confederate flag this is important one
too because
there are even some conservatives that
would defend that one and so oh it
shouldn't be a Confederate flag flying
what I've always said about this is that
when it comes to any Monument anything
like that you know no one is saying
that every single
flag that's ever been raised every
monument that's ever been erected has to
stay forever and that we can never take
it down under any circumstance no one is
saying that
so
if there's something you want to take
down
you make your argument you explain why
you should take it down
but you do that on your own terms
what you never ever do is is do it in
response to the Mob
so if you've got a good argument for
taking down a monument
um
you make that argument at a time when
the mob isn't demanding it
the fact that the mob demands it is is
reason enough to not do it
even if otherwise you you could make an
argument for it
if the mob demands it you don't do it
that again is leadership
you never cave to the demands of the mob
so Nikki Haley not the one we need in
this moment or any other moment
this little New York Post there are
hundreds if not thousands of unknown
objects soaring in the skies but they're
likely just used car balloons or other
benign crafts and not aliens visiting
Earth according to White House officials
on Monday
White House Homeland Security advisor
Liz Sherwood Randall said in a virtual
briefing quote there are no UFOs this is
not an invasion of aliens
I mean it's funny but it's not funny
because people are communicating this on
platforms that are widely viewed
but despite Sherwood Randall's Assurance
to the elected officials the government
is still unable to identify the trio of
recently downed objects the first was
shot down off of Alaska's Arctic
Coastline on Friday the second over
Canada's Yukon Territory Saturday and
the third over Lake Huron on Sunday
on the call to Governors on Monday
Sherwin Randall said there are hundreds
if not thousands of objects in the sky
most are believed to be mundane and
could be things like used car balloons
or aircraft launched by commercial
businesses she added
well like I said yesterday if you needed
any more confirmation that these are
definitely aliens
that
that this has to be it use car balloons
yeah there's a a balloon from a used car
lot has become dislodged and is now 40
000 feet in the sky and is moving around
in a way that utterly perplexes Navy
Pilots That's one of the say what you
want about the UFO theories but
you know keep in mind that in many of
these cases including what happened uh
over the weekend
you've got trained pilots who this is
this is what they do and they have laid
eyes on these objects and they come back
and report I can't I don't know what
that is and I don't know how it's moving
away around the way that it is I'm I'm
pretty sure that a like a Navy pilot
knows what a balloon looks like and
could easily and a use are you talking
about what used car balloons are we
talking about first so we talk about
those ones the uh the craziest the ones
with the the wacky arm ones
I assume that's what they're talking
about because that's like when you think
of a used car balloon that's the first
thing that comes to mind right
wouldn't that be really distinct
if you saw that somehow floating in the
sky 40 000 feet in the air I don't know
how it gets up that high like I know
that a wind gust can take a balloon
pretty far but like give me a break
but wouldn't that be the most distinct
and obvious thing in the world I mean it
would that be pretty clear that's what
it is now but you have a lot of
questions about how it got up there
maybe
it was aliens that brought it up there
but I I think you'll know that's what it
is and when you've got the Navy Pilots
coming back and saying you know this was
a cylindrical object I don't know how it
was there were Generals you know General
in the Air Force
just a couple of days ago was saying I
don't know what these things are I don't
know what their propulsion method is uh
I don't know how they're staying in the
sky and I'm not ruling out alien
activity
it was from a general in the Air Force
only a few days ago and now they're
saying oh no it's a used car balloon
that's all it was
look I'm not saying it was aliens well I
am saying I've been saying that the
whole time
but
even if you still are not convinced by
my many compelling arguments in that
direction it is it's like clearly
there's there's something going on and
they are hiding it I think we could all
agree on that whatever it is they're not
being honest about it and it seemed like
they were caught off whatever it is they
were caught off guard by it
um and they didn't have the story
straight initially
because if they were expecting it and
they were competent people
um then they and they didn't want us to
know it was really gone then they would
have come out from the beginning and
said oh it's just a bunch of balloons
don't worry yeah as a child in fact as a
kid at Chuck E cheese was having a
birthday party and uh and there's a
bunch of balloons of balloons when the
sky is all it was it's all it's on our
radar you know it happens all the time
happens all the time that kids have
birthday parties and uh balloons go in
the sky and then we dispatch uh Jets to
go investigate you know all the time it
happens that's all it is they would have
said that from the beginning
they would have said that if that was
the case
um or even if they were determined to
cover it up and they and they had their
wits about them and were not caught off
guard then they would have said that
from the beginning the fact that we're
seeing this drastic change
again just a few days ago it was they
they would not rule out they wouldn't
publicly even on the record rule out the
possibility of UFOs alien spacecraft and
now they're saying use car ballots
whatever it is they know more than
they're telling us and they don't want
us to know what they know
all right
um
hey one other thing but I think we're
going to save it for tomorrow
because we have to get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
you know there's a certain holiday in
February very near and dear to all of us
here at the daily wire it's normally
meant to show appreciation for a special
someone uh they've had a lot of
influence in your life so some
recognition is warranted at the least
but we haven't quite taken that usual
approach here of course the holiday I'm
talking about is President's Day right
now over at delawire.com shop we're
celebrating the our president is for
sale sale you'll find great deals up to
40 off on select daily wire merchandise
including highlights from my swag Shack
like the Johnny The Walrus plushie
bundle which is at its lowest price ever
and the matte wall superfan bundle
they're alongside other bestsellers like
the leftist tears tumblers and the daily
wire dog bundle too
what is that exactly is that something
stuff for your dog why do they put that
in my copy so anyway don't wait on
taking advantage of this sale head over
to dailywire.com shop today
CJ says the decline of understanding
love everyone to mean let people do
whatever they want and don't interfere
is a direct consequence of people not
having children as a parent you learn
that what that statement truly means you
love your children Beyond description
yet you don't let them do whatever they
want you're often the bad guy in their
lives as you stop them from destroying
themselves on a regular basis because of
the love that you have for them
um yeah that's what that's how good
parents operate anyway
um and you're right that I I think there
is an interesting connection that you've
drawn there
um
just it becomes very clear it's not that
you can't understand this without having
kids but it does become
very clear once you have kids that um
oftentimes the most loving thing to do
is is to offer correction
even punishment like the I so you can
understand maybe intellectually that
correction and Punishment okay can can
often be uh fueled by the love for the
person that you're correcting and
punishing
but it's an intellectual exercise and
then you have kids and you really
understand it you really understand what
that what that means that you'll love
your your children you love your child
more than life itself and because of
that you're forced to correct them
you're forced sometimes to punish
um I know that and I'm not alone in this
but as a parent I
you know I uh there are times when I've
had to come down pretty hard on my kids
because they've done something that
warrants you know a more um
a more severe response and I don't I
hate it I don't I don't like it I don't
like punishing my kids which is good I
think if you if you enjoyed it there'd
be something wrong
but I really don't like it it's I find
it actually quite painful because it's
not
the kind of it's not what I wanted it's
not what I want to do and especially if
I you know it's the days when I come
home from work and uh instead of one of
the kids was acting up and of course
like I'm you know dad comes home for
work I gotta have to deal with that
sometimes
but
um it's not what I want to do like I
come I I don't I don't I don't want to
have to have that kind of interaction
but
I do it because I'm the father and this
is what we are supposed to do
I also understand as I become a parent I
I understand parents that spoil their
kids and let the kids run run wild and
do whatever they want I don't it's not
how I parent don't get me wrong and it's
the wrong way to parent but I can
understand the emotional like
inclination that leads you in that
direction because you just you know you
you it's it's hard to correct your kids
all the time and it's even emotionally
painful at times
um but that is that's what it means to
love someone that's that's what if you
if you want what's best for them and
also means you want them to be a better
person you want someone to be a good
person
you really want if you love someone
that's what you want for them you want
them to be good fulfilled people
which means you don't just leave them to
wander the Earth on their own and figure
out things as they go along you have to
you have to cut a path for them and when
they go off that path you have to
correct them and sometimes like drag
them Kicking and Screaming back to the
right path
um
Samuel says Matt I agree with almost
everything you espouse but I'm confused
the ad simply said love your enemy it
didn't say love their sin or love their
actions just love them as Christians we
need to bring people into Christianity
gradually we cannot cold turkey people
into Christ also the ad serves its
purpose whether there was hate on both
sides or not there was hate and that is
what the ad was targeting finally I
think you missed a chance to accept some
of God's word into your life you
immediately went to Defending Your Side
from imaginary attack instead of using
the ad to realize that you could do with
a bit of loving your enemies all love
I don't I don't think that you quite
understood my criticism I'm not saying
that we shouldn't love our enemies what
I am saying is that
um
I'm saying a few things first of all
that is when it comes to the Christian
message that is the easiest thing to say
uh it's the thing that's going to be the
most crowd-pleasing and popular even
though in this case you know because AOC
is a is a ditz she she still found a
reason to complain about it but
generally it's the most kind of
crowd-pleasing message doesn't make it
wrong it's just that's what it is and so
I think that if you're gonna if you're
gonna go with that then I it behooves
you to say a little bit more about it to
say something useful about to Simply say
and leave it at this
you know the simply say whoa love your
enemy it's like here's a bunch of people
yelling at each other that's bad love
your enemy I I I'm sorry I just don't
see that as a useful message because
you're left people wondering what does
that mean like how do we love them
exactly is it does it just mean think
nice things about each other and hold
hands and say kubia Kumbaya because
that's what people think and that's the
kind of message they often get from the
Christian churches keep in mind that in
the Bible Jesus says love your enemy but
he doesn't just leave it at that and if
you read the entire context of scripture
you get a pretty good idea of what
loving your enemy really means
and so I I simply think that a message
like this or you got the music in the
background is very inspirational don't
yell at each other love each other all
right I mean fine it's fine it's it's
you know it's it's inoffensive
but I also just don't I do not think
it's useful what people need is to
understand what loving your enemy
actually means and they need to
understand that sometimes loving your
enemy does involve anger it could even
involve raising your voice and and and
yelling a little bit sometimes that that
can happen out of love yes that could be
fueled by love absolutely and I think
that that's a message that needs to be
understood I just think that this that
ad again basically benign inoffensive
nothing about it that's explicitly wrong
necessarily but
um
it all adds up to this sort of General
picture which is quite wrong
that Christian love means basically
getting along with everyone and never
getting angry
um and I think we've had quite enough of
that I don't think we need more of it if
you are going to spend 20 million
dollars on an ad for the Super Bowl like
how about say something
that how about say something that people
aren't already Gonna Hear everywhere
like everyone has heard that Kumbaya get
along everyone hears that
how about say something a message that
they won't hear anywhere else
um
no Beggars can't be choosers and all
that when it comes to Super Bowl ads so
it's like at least it wasn't uh depraved
and say overly overtly sexual and all
the rest of it but
um I do think we've reached a point in
this culture where we got to do more we
got to do more than Kumbaya that's all
to celebrate President's Day this year
the daily wire is running our presidents
for sale sale
um which uh you know you probably hadn't
heard about this you heard about five
five minutes ago and I just talked about
it but anyway once again with 40 off for
new annual memberships the big guy got
10 we're giving you 40 get access to the
world of daily wire plus with Fearless
documentaries gripping movies Dennis
Prager is the Masters program and the
entire library of Jordan Peterson's work
including new productions like Exodus
logos and literacy and on marriage all
available to watch right now as soon as
you become a member coming down the
pipeline to a TV or laptop near you
we've got new episodes of Ben Shapiro's
the search Exodus part two our much
anticipated DW kids content and much
more all coming up and to sweeten the
deal like ice cream well we're going to
give you up to 40 off select items in
the daily wire shop take advantage of
the our president's for sale sale today
you know he would so just go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
daily wire member today that's
dailywire.com
subscribe now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well it should perhaps tell you
something about the cultural relevance
of the New York Times that a New York
Times columnist wrote an entire
editorial responding to one of my tweets
and I just found out about it today a
week after it was published I didn't
even know that it happened
and that writer is David French a man
who still pretends to be a conservative
and yet is notorious for articles like
the one he wrote in October for the
dispatch where he complained that laws
being passed to protect children from
the trans agenda are taking the culture
War too far and quote threatening
foundational American Rights
so he's a conservative who is deeply
repelled by anything or any idea that
can be remotely described as
conservative
that's exactly what earned him a spot at
the New York Times because the times
like CNN is only interested in
conservatives whose conservatism
consists of complaining about attacking
and straw Manning conservatives
that's exactly what David French did in
his latest New York Times op-ed which
was written in response to my now
Infamous tweet a couple of weeks ago
where I made the Apparently radical
claim that men want loving wives and
they appreciate hot meals
really offensive stuff and French could
not let such extremism stand
unchallenged
and that's why he wrote this it begins
this month the popular conservative
podcaster Matt Walsh tweeted a thought
that rapidly went viral with
approximately 18 million views all a man
wants he wrote is to come home from a
long day at work to a grateful wife and
children who are glad to see him and
dinner cooking on the stove this is
literally all it takes to make a man
happy we are simple give us this and you
have given us nearly everything we need
the message French says was obviously
trollish and intended to generate
outrage bringing back Leave it to Beaver
is not a serious strategy for for
renewing American masculinity but it
touched on an important question
how much should a man's self-worth
depend on the respect or gratitude of
others
right trollish and meant to generate
outrage why else would I suggest that
men enjoy coming home to a happy and
loving family I mean why why why why
should such an outrageous claim be made
except to troll people that's the only
reason right
it's a deliberate provocation intended
to sow chaos
now they're really only two possible
reasons why French would frame my
statements this way
one is that he's an intellectual coward
who isn't confident in his ability to
actually articulate a rebuttal to my
ideas and so he must frame them as
unserious and beneath him from the
outset even though he's dedicating his
entire column to responding to them
the other possibility is that the
conservative quote unquote David French
is such an extreme leftist so radically
far left in his thinking that he really
does consider my incredibly normal
description of a normal family to be
somehow shocking and outrageous
I can't say for sure which of these
options is closer to the mark but I
guess that the truth is maybe a
combination of the two
French continues
I raised this because an overwhelming
amount of evidence from suicide to drug
overdose to education achievement gaps
indicates that millions of men are in
crisis simply put while many men demand
respect what they need is purpose and
the Quest for respect can sometimes
undermine the sense of purpose that will
help them make that will help make them
whole
to put it more simply still what men
need is not for others to do things for
them they need to do things for others
for spouses for children for family and
friends and colleagues
okay now
he's not wrong obviously that men need
purpose
I say that all the time
I never suggested that they don't need
purpose in fact in the tweet that he's
responding to I suggest exactly the
opposite the reason why a man finds joy
in returning home from A Hard Day's Work
to a warm and loving home is that it
strengthens and vindicates and validates
his purpose in life
in that moment he feels fully grounded
in his purpose he knows what his purpose
is a man who returns home to a loving
family returns home to his purpose
now French either doesn't understand
that or again is pretending to not
understand it
we'll read one more passage just to get
the full uh context of his argument
quote the demand for respect is a
Hallmark of much right-wing discourse
about masculinity in this narrative too
many women don't respect their husbands
and the culture more broadly devalues
men part of this argument has Merit yet
there's a danger in the Quest for
respect finding happiness in another
person's regard is Elusive and
contingent after all we have little true
control over how others perceive or
treat us yet when we're denied what we
demand we're often filled with helpless
rage more important a demand for respect
or honor should be conditioned on being
respectable or honorable when a man
demands respect without being
respectable that often looks like
domination and subordination to elevate
himself he must belittle others virtuous
purpose is worth more than any other
person's conditional and unreliable
respect it is rooted in service and
sacrifice not entitlement and those
qualities bring a degree of meaning and
joy far more important than the gift
that others The Grateful spouse who
cooks dinner the implausibly reverential
children can ever offer what we do for
others is infinitely more rewarding than
what we ask them to do for us
okay
all of that is response to the tweet
that I wrote
now again not everything he's saying
here is wrong I'm not going to play the
Frenchy in Game of pretending that some
relatively normal idea is outrageous and
offensive but you have to read between
the lines a little bit and also keep in
mind the statement my statement that his
argument is supposed to rebut
and when you take into account that
context you see that French's point is
one that in fact every left-wing
feminist would agree with though even
they wouldn't put it as explicit as he
has here
men should not want anything men have no
right to desire anything least of all
should they have any emotional needs men
are meant to operate in a vacuum where
they pursue purpose entirely unaffected
by their surroundings
now on the surface it may sound like
French is of anything making the mistake
of being too tough you know having
standards that are too high expecting
men to be too Duty bound and stoic
that's not the case at all in fact he's
calling men to submissiveness
he considers it outrageous that a man
should hold his wife to any standard at
all okay remember all he said of the
three is a grateful wife so that's a
stance that is a standard that I am
putting on the woman that is something
that I am saying a woman should do God
forbid we mention one single thing that
a woman might should do herself in a
marriage
French doesn't like that
the idea that a man should have any
expectations that a man should want
anything is offensive even wanting your
children to be happy to see you is
French says implausible
remember again what I said what French
is respond to the only thing I said
about children
I didn't say that when you walk in the
door children should bow should do a
profound bow and say father we are we
are grateful to be in your presence once
more no I said that fathers want their
children to be glad to see them and
grateful for them
French dismisses the very idea that your
children should want to see you calling
it implausibly reverential
maybe we're learning something about how
his own kids treat him I don't know I
just I can't understand otherwise why
you would consider it implausible that
your children will be happy you walked
in the door
because a man who simply wants his
family to be glad that he walked in the
door is according to French engaging in
some kind of Leave it to Beaver fever
dream
men should instead just shut up and do
as they're told men should focus on
doing for others without being remotely
affected by how they are treated in
return
talk about implausible I mean if my
vision for men is Leave it to Beaver
then his is like Spock he envisions man
as unfeeling inhuman creatures no
desires or emotions to speak of
and you'll notice that French
this is what's most important to see
he has never and would never say
anything like this about women he would
never not in a million years lecture
women for wanting respect he would never
say that a woman who wants gratitude
from her husband is being an outrageous
troll
he would never say that a woman who
expresses her emotional needs is
engaging in some kind of ludicrous
fantasy and shouldn't even be taken
seriously
that's because this is not French being
like a hard-ass drill sergeant barking
at everyone to stop whining and just get
on with it if it was I'd be sympathetic
to his approach even if I disagreed with
his argument but instead French is
cowering to the feminist double standard
which says that men can never talk about
what they want
only women can do that
because that is the thing that upset
everyone that's why they're still
talking about that tweet two weeks later
because I dared to say one single thing
about what men want
you're not allowed to do that ever and
David French is here to enforce that
rule
now in reality of course
um
in this contest between purpose and
respect a contest that French has
created largely because he feels
compelled to find some reason to
disagree with me
the answer is both
men need purpose and respect you cannot
remove one from the occasion equation
without severely diminishing the other a
man who has respect will be more likely
to under to understand and and uh his
purpose and a man with purpose is more
likely to have respect
what this means for a wife
is that if you are a wife and you want
to help your husband live with purpose
then you should respect him
and show that respect and make sure that
he sees it and feels it that doesn't
mean respect is entirely unconditional
it doesn't mean that a man should be
respected no matter what he does at all
it simply means that if you love your
husband and you want him to be happy
and especially if you realize that he's
trying his best even if it's not perfect
he's not a perfect person
who's trying
and you want to be the best version of
himself that he can be
then you will help fuel him in that
direction which means showing him
respect
you know my wife
will often say to me not every day not
following some kind of script or
timeline but she she will often say that
she appreciates how hard I work for the
family she's grateful for the sacrifices
I make she'll sometimes say that to me
in person somebody she'll send me a text
just randomly during the day when I'm at
work with a message like that
she lets me know that she notices and
she cares and that it matters to her
and that yes she's grateful
these kinds of acknowledgments they fuel
me and motivate me in a way that nothing
else can
you know I am very happy to have a
loving and grateful wife and children
guess what yeah my kids are also happy
when I walk in the door
I didn't I never knew that was
implausible but this implausible fantasy
has come has come into fruition in my
own life if you can believe it
and there are many other men who have
the same happiness
and I want those who don't have that
happiness to experience it
that was my whole point
and yes it was a point that focused on
the needs of men
much could be said about the needs of of
of of men
um or rather what men should do there'll
be there are plenty of things that could
be said about the responsibilities of
men much could be said about what men
should do for their wives
and much is said about that all the time
it's okay to flip the coin over and look
at the other side from time to time it's
not only okay but necessary
even if it offends guys like David
French
with the New York Times
who is today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]